now is this a surprise
centaur while you
[Music]
[Music]
citizen I'm warning your presence is
interfering with Imperial business
begone
you know any true sons and daughters
[Music]
Oh
what happened
Gallus guide to you
the next Imperial I see
[Music]
vault series close with the Dragons
about official business only
[Music]
fine
but we'll be keeping an eye on you
[Music]
[Music]
we'll pay whatever it takes but we must
have more swords for the Imperial
soldiers
they say Helgen got hit by a dragon one
of those horrors comes here
I work with my mother
[Music]
Thank You Man
staying safe I hope
what's the meaning of this interruption
y'all Baldwin is not receiving visitors
well that explains why the guards let
you in come on this the y'all will want
to speak to you sir oh you were at Hogan
you saw this dragon with your own eyes
[Music]
by Speer he roulette was right
what do you say now prevents us so we
continued to trust in the strength of
our walls against the dragon my lord we
should send troops to Riverwood at once
it's in the most immediate danger if
that dragon is lurking in the mountain
super preparing overexcited attack him
I'll not stand idly by while the dragon
burns my hold and slaughters my people
IRRI let's send a detachment to
Riverwood at once
yes my Yong if you'll excuse me I'll
return to my duties that would be best
well done you sought me out on your own
initiative you've done Whiterun a
service I won't forget it here take this
as a small token of my esteem
there is another thing you could do for
me
suitable for someone come let's go find
far in guard my court wizard he's been
looking into a matter related to these
dragons
fahren guy I think I found someone who
can help you with your dragon project go
ahead and fill her in with all the
details by I smear a thief
so the old things you can be used to me
yes I can use someone to fetch something
for me well when I say fetch
[Music]
[Music]
you